[Music]
Sounds like
you've been listening to us for a long time Oh, if you say that, it's like you've been eavesdropping Because it's
not
true  You don't have to do it ah ah ah
That's why I was curious Then the rule came in at a part-time job, right?
It's December, so I'm going to be absent from school
Oh
, I'm fine.
Hey, I'll never lose in my studies,
so I'm taking a successor, and the last mock exam was a pass grade, and I
'm still in my second year of high school, but I'm going to go to college.
But if that's the case, I don't think there's time to talk about Antarctica, but there are still nearly two years until the exam,
and
next year I'm seriously studying for the exam, so I'd like to do at least one
thing this year.  If I don't do it, I can't do it
anymore.  I'm a type. Outline of
strategy.